two or three days ago I got a letter
from one of our fans and it's different
from any other letter that we've ever
had because this fan young has attached
to it a sample of an element and what's
more it was an element that I never seen
it's scandium it's a really small piece
but cording to my colleague Steve it's
very expensive element so this might be
quite valuable and scandium is a really
interesting element much more
interesting than I realized
when I first talked about it on the
video scandium is an element which
chemists usually ignore I never use
scandium in any of my research it was
one of the elements that Mendeleev
predicted ought to exist when he first
devised the periodic table when he made
it there were lots of elements that were
not known but what he did was to predict
that there were holes in various places
where he felt there ought to be an
element and because these elements
obviously didn't have names he called
them iike boron or iike aluminium iike
silicon meaning underneath those
elements and the triumphs of the
periodic table was that people actually
discovered these elements and the first
one that was discovered was the element
gallium iike aluminium and the second
one was iike boron which is scandium now
you might think it's a bit surprising
because if you look at the modern
periodic table scandium and boron are
really quite a long way apart but in the
original way that Mendeleev started the
periodic table when he wrote it down
first scandium and boron came very close
together because both of them have three
electrons in their outer shell which
makes their chemistry quite similar of
course Mendeleev didn't know about
electrons but he guessed from looking at
titanium which has four electrons and
calcium which has two that he thought
there was something missing and what's
also interesting about these three
elements that he predicted that they all
ended up with names of country
there was gallium that was named after
France from the Latin word from France
scandium that was named after well
perhaps not a country but two regions
Scandinavia
and then germanium that was named after
Germany the first time that an element
was discovered when gallium was
discovered people said well it was just
luck
but when scandium was discovered they
really began to take Mendeleev pretty
seriously and by the time germanium was
came was discovered they really all
decided that Mendeleev was right
scandium because it's quite an uncommon
element is one where people don't know
much about the chemistry I've never
really done any research in this area
but like many elements suddenly there
comes a time where they become really
quite popular and topical and now is the
time for scandium and the reason is that
scandium is a very light metal it's
density is slightly less than four
that's four grams per cubic centimeter
and that's very much lighter than most
metals copper is nearly ten and lead and
gold are close to twenty so this is
really very light so why shouldn't
metals be important if they're light and
that's the reason is that sometimes you
want to use a metal but you don't want
the object that you make to be very
heavy and so for example titanium which
is very light is used for making
everything from golf clubs to jet
fighter planes where you want it to be
really light either so you can swing it
fast or fly fast for scandium the
reasons rather different people are now
thinking about using hydrogen to power
cars to use hydrogen gas as the fuel to
power cars but what they want to do is
to store the hydrogen in the equivalent
of the
tank you can't just pressurize the
hydrogen as in a gas cylinder because
the container would be so heavy that
your car would be like a military tank
it would be so heavy so what they want
to try and do is to produce a chemical
compound which is a bit like a sponge
that will absorb the hydrogen and then
for example if you warm it gently the
hydrogen will come out and it is here
that you want the metal to be light
because you want this material that
you're using to store hydrogen not to
weigh very much because you've got to
cart it around in your car all the time
and scandium compounds and now looking
really quite promising for storage of
hydrogen and the idea is that rather
like a molecular model kit where you
have bulls joined with sticks you can
use organic compounds those of carbon
and hydrogen with a little oxygen like
sticks to join together scandium atoms
and produce a structure which has a lot
of holes in it and then the hydrogen can
go into those holes and be stored
without needing an enormous pressure
sounds like an incredibly complicated
way to make a fuel tank it is quite
complicated but on the other hand if it
works you don't need to understand the
chemistry you just add the hydrogen to
your tank and away you go
how can you have got to your ripe old
age as a chemist and never have seen
Scandia well chemists very often use
compounds salts of metals but it's not
so often that you use the metal itself
and salts because they don't have to be
purified and so on quite as much as the
metals are easier to get they're not as
expensive and so there are lots of the
elements I have
scene but I'm really quite pleased with
this sample of scandium so when I'm
finished I'm going to frame it and hang
it on my wall so we have one of our
students works with one of my colleagues
Martin Schroeder and this student has
been done his whole project three-year
project on the chemistry of scandium so
when I got this letter I asked him have
you ever seen and scandium and he hadn't
he'd never seen the metal so he was
really quite excited to see John's
letter